[Music]
what do you know about this movie uh
Steven Lang is in it and that's it do
you know who Steven Lang is yeah I do
can you name a very famous film he was
in are you gonna quiz me all movie or
how's this gonna go just just this one
question is all you get competition time
who can hold their breath for longer
three two
1 okay don't breathe PGE we're watching
don't breathe it's a horror movie and uh
I just won that competition you did you
got buried by me you win every
competition we play I don't know if
that's true it's true but I did win this
one and it's because I used to hold my
breath in tunnels every single time you
try to make it do that too yeah what's
up with that hands up eyes closed
holding the breath making a wish how you
doing Happy 2024 I'm doing well how are
you I'm doing well same me still in this
posture you know who else is doing
well who you weren't even going to try
to take a guess I was about to the
rejects the re citizens of the reject
happy yall exactly if you are here with
us we're so grateful please don't forget
like comment subscribe if I was ter say
ring that
Bell
whoa Purge you're finally catching along
you want to be super sexy reject then go
ahead over to our patreon sync up with
your own copy Greg and John exclusively
do watch alongs and things I would tell
you exactly what it said if Greg made
this in a font that I could read in any
way shape or form that was even close
legible thank you so much to prepper for
helping us edit down this video are you
ready to do this I'm ready to hold my
breath I'll film the whole time the
whole time okay let's do
[Music]
it I hate that sound it's like nails on
a
chalkboard yeah is that on
purpose it's to set the mood for what
we're in
for
New Year same city way bigger houses on
the right than the left what is the
financial disparity here I know feel
there's a social commentary they're
they're trying to tell us here about the
the right side and the left side here
but it's like when you drive down
Beverly Hills and it's LA and Beverly
Hills and half the road's paved and half
of it is not true this is all cracks say
crack again
crack dragging a dead
body oh that's not a crack that's a
blood trail I see I see oh that's a
quite the
[Music]
reveal I think she wins the don't
breathe
contest
Jesus 19 18 Roy those are very slow
seconds yo kill that already that's
funny we heard 2019 I thought they were
saying the year
2019 10
N I told you this was going to be fancy
oh what movie is she in I don't know but
that's dlan Reet I know one 13 reasons
why the guy on the left
yep okay so this is a a robbery oh I
feel like they could have gotten some
nicer shoes in
there now I know
her
what oh God giving the house a new paint
job so it must be personal cuz they're
not just taking things okay let's get
out of
here interesting that they wanted to set
the alarm off yeah cuz they could have
got away clean there yeah it's either
personal or they're just in it for the
thrill no must be personal otherwise
you're not peeing and lying in the bed
yeah yeah I don't know if I'm right but
no no I mean you you make a very ladybug
you make a very valid point do you make
a wish on a ladybug or
no I don't make a wish usually but I
usually like keeping them I just think
they're so cool we keep hitting houses
like today's Rocky and bye-bye
Detroit and Alla California well okay
keep hitting houses so maybe not
personal everyone has wronged them
you're going away rock yeah as soon as I
can when are you coming back
never he loves her what
everyone else is gone I got my dad here
so he's doing it for the money he's got
to help his dad
dad you're
home huh a slight change in music that
was interesting there
too so is his dad in real estate or why
does he have all of
the home security Ah that's why they
made it look like it was a Breakin
through the window cuz they don't want
anybody know they Ed the key cuz his dad
would get in trouble yep yo this is it
Manus my 40% Rolex in there bro what do
you think I'm going to put it up on a s
be yeah know how much people on the
street pay for a hot relics Black Market
you want money then steal money [__]
bro his money symbol tattoo is so
aggressive you know what I like money
it's almost as subtle as the damaged
Joker no family just him in the house
some pry girl few years ago I over this
guy's daughter Jesus daughter dies and
this pry Rich ass family pays him off
gives him a big ass sediment sediment me
your
honor his breathing is freaking me out
hey always seems like he's out of breath
do you think the money's in the house I
don't know let's go find out guys no we
don't do cash that amount brings a
serious cop presence I'll do an
investigation my dad could get in
trouble need [__] out man if we do this
right we never have to do it again ooh
she's maybe he doesn't need the money
though because he does seem like the
preppy boy compared to the other two
we're not doing this
one seriously maybe he knows the girl
who got killed or
something they put a lot of red under
her nose I wonder if this is a drug
thing you need to get out of here please
do this for me why did they sh like that
yeah it's hard to read
interesting
oh and some investigative work they blur
a lot in this movie interesting go for
vetan just six figure
settlement oh we're in Gross Point gross
Point's
nice you done Diddy be a doll and get
your mother a large four cheese from
Tony's so Trevor's is living here now oh
it was the Gross Point person that hit
them don't be a [__] roxan is just a
few months till he can find a new job
roxan don't be a [__] Rock
in you have no money in here you pay for
it then I know you're making money got
to wonder why she would want to get out
of there and move to LA such a stable
home that's what this rock sand did I'm
her I want to go to the beach yeah well
it's not summer monkey head I want to be
a surfer there's no Surfer
in Michigan some things you can't change
baby no matter how unfair they are what
a
bummer agreed
babe he's like I did my research let's
do it
California what do you say you and I
move there together would you like
that both their eyes are
huge what's the horror movie with Justin
long and the it's the person mother
downstairs not jeepers creep no no no
recently oh um oh oh last year Barbarian
oh uh that street looks like the
Barbarian street is that a new tattoo
yeah I got it last night is it a ladybug
oh when my dad left my mom started
drinking and she told me that my dad's
leaving was all my fault that's nice
blam everything on your kids and I
missed them a lot so I'd cry she got so
fed up with the crying that she would
lock me in the trunk of her car good
parenting yeah sounds like a wonderful
mother a little hole in the trunk and
one time a ladybug flew in kept me
company when I reach California I'm
going to color this tat and that's the
last time I will mark my body if we get
this money I'm going away with you
guys I know you will there'll be a
family yeah but this guy's going to mess
it all up I was going to say he does
seem like the the Wild Card guys a shot
and hasn't left his house in like 5 days
so we do it with him in the house I'll
get a Chlor bomb
jeez Purge
Purge that no that freaked me too no
that really got me that was not a fake
reaction I promise you guys I how could
that have been fake I mean you just I
literally not to be asked but you just
look like a little
[__] thank you appreciate it I did I
did so I guess that was a fair comment
sorry that's saying I didn't think it
was F fake cuz you really wait is he
blind he's lost his sight in Iraq or
something it's kind of up to rob a blind
guy isn't it just cuz he's blind don't
mean he's insane bro oh when I go see
horror films in theaters which is very
rare I'm sorry hoodie over my head that
was so mean of me I'm sorry I'm sorry
it's all good you are forgiven I'm very
I'm very I I I listen there's a little
bee in all of us there's a little be in
all of
us cool shot very cool I can't really
see anything but very cool yeah but I I
loved that yeah no no it was very cool
though I mean anything it's too a.m.
he's sleeping take care of that dog
first yeah I love when you can just see
the faces or Silhouettes some could say
I love the darkness ah you think
darkness is your ally born in it raised
by it you merely adopted the
dark oh
man I really like this girl
oh imagine that's going to put it I'm
sure they're just going to put it to
sleep I don't think I don't think
they're going to hurt
it just going to put it to
sleep I'm under the assumption they
think this is a 5 minute job there's
four locks you got the other keys well I
only have the one why wouldn't he give
backup keys to the security company cuz
the money's in there and the paranoid
doesn't trust nobody no it's it's a
setup why wouldn't he give backup keys
to the security company that's the
question oh no I'm just worried cuz a
dog jump scare got me really bad so I'm
like I'm like feel self-conscious I'm
sorry no no no no no I'm not even
worried about that I'm just like I get
it really bad so I'm like really you'll
be okay I'm probably not you will any
thoughts right now on why it's called
Don't
breathe I feel like they're about to get
kidnapped
well I definitely feel like they're
walking into some kind of I think he
didn't give backup keys because he keeps
people in here this is some kind I mean
yeah we saw at the beginning he was
dragging a body so well we saw a body
being dragged
right this gu is messing
up oh my God oh my God not the fingers
not the fingers oh oh no no
no and you are making a lot of noise
what about that
window there's no bars on it I can fit
in there oh no I feel like they're going
into the home of like a future older M
or Kevin McAllister it's just a home
full of traps I think that this is like
a black phone
situation oh oh oh
oh the hands coming in and us not
knowing what's on the other side yeah no
it's your your imagination's just
playing like what is on the other side
side
uhoh you don't get I suddenly I hate
this
movie it's definitely already very
suspenseful
no honestly I'm having a hard time
breathing
yeah no no no no no Purge Purge
okay we're like 20 minutes in whoa that
was close no no no no no no no do not
settle in yet do not sett I mean she's
about to get grabbed something something
five four three two
one five four three going to have a
bunch of five second
[Music]
countdowns
you're just preparing yourself yeah
just why is it upside down uh well they
said his daughter right was yeah why was
it upside down cuz she's in a grave
somewh I don't know she must have got it
by now she's
fine yeah I can really give a what you
say that's my [__] in there of course I
give a all I want to be is somebody's
[__] be a good friend and stay in the
[__] [__] friends
of we got a little triangle going on
here shoes
off shoes off well I think they want to
avoid making
noise side but I just also like that
can't be the right choice I mean they've
made noise already they broke a window
the alarm was going off yeah he knows
they're in the house no doubt he
does what is their intention with him I
mean they want to steal cash but no
intention with him like they're just
hoping he doesn't wake up and if he does
they're goingon to Chlor form
him locked that's where they he's
keeping people oh there's got to be some
body or hearts or so who knows what he's
done in
there this is giving dmer even Freddy
Krueger had a boiler room you know I
don't think I've ever seen Friday the
13th it's is that what that movie is
Freddy Krueger's Nightmare and El Street
you know what I don't think I've ever
seen Nightmare on El Street Friday the
13th is
Jason okay I haven't seen either I don't
think I've only seen Halloween I'm only
recently into horror films and I'm
loving them yeah I think you'd like
those is it a gun that's taped under I
think it's just so hard to
see oh is he asleep I don't know I doubt
it very obviously not asleep just I so
wow
okay you're right he's
[Music]
not what is it he's drugging
is okay is it possible he's not the only
one in the house maybe I don't yeah
darn guy's gassed out he's he's he's out
he's in Sleeping Beauty more it's fine
guys that's why it's called Don't
breathe think you can grack it
[Applause]
open maybe he's keeping like Monsters
down there or something like maybe they
shouldn't come
outus I thought he was the bad guy but I
don't know I mean I think these are the
I mean even though we sympathize with
them they're still they're stealing but
for sure I'm just thinking I thought he
was keeping people in his basement
because that's true I guess evil they're
all antagonists but maybe he's not I'm
going to pop that [__] like again do you
have any idea we bringing a gun to a
Burg he means he gives me a better
chance to defend myself Alex we mean you
just gave this guy the legal right to
shoot us yep let's go no no no no I
think we should stay we have to leave
this is not good yes get out logicality
that's a different
movie oh
silencer
oh no so out good oh no he's not going
to be able to
leave oh no what's in there no no no no
no no no
no hey man just chill all right I I I
was wasted and and I I wandered in so
that that was my bet all right so I'm
just going to I'm just going to leave
okay what was that
oh it's
lock oh
don't I know what's in there and I ain't
leaving without it take one single step
all right uh dude is built like a train
s don't you
move Pass
Me
Jesus dude keep doing what you were
doing go run away stop
who
oh
[__] guess there's the old saying make
him think you're weak when you're strong
how many of you are
there how
many I'm by myself just me man all right
just me just let me
go oh no oh no don't try to help him do
not
oh he's so going to shoot him okay I swe
to
go
snikes oh this dude is crazy I mean
technically that is someone's
trespassing on your property but I mean
that was the the what that was the crazy
route and the guy had a gun at him but
still it's like how did he get out of
the gas room upstairs where is Dylan
man's character and what's downstairs in
regards to the gas question you asked I
would assume he heard him in there and
he was just holding his breath knowing
that that went off it's it oh
no oh you should have oh my God God damn
it Dylan that's a different
movie
Purge
oh you are now locked in sir you should
have stayed out stay out the sequel to
get
out oh dear Lord oh I would not want to
be locked in a house with that
man now I understand why it's called
Don't
breathe
I can't believe he didn't leave I mean
he's in love Yeah but he told her to
come with
him she's going to text for
help do not text him right now his
phone's going to go off all the guys in
there yeah
no no yeah he will hear
that oh smart he put it on
vibrate he's going to be like yes I can
pursue her now
man
right is now a good time for like I told
you so feel like Dylan should say that
to
her I would wait till you get out of the
house but and you can say that a bunch
of times but he definitely owes her a
lot of those we always see people in
movies do this to keep themselves quiet
do you think that helps it seems to be
right now oh
no oh well think they found the money
what's the
code wow it says right on there 2978
what do you think that date means so
February 9th 1978 what happened I don't
know because we saw in that video that
his daughter I it was what like 1998 or
something so that's can't be his
daughter's
birthday there's still got to be
something downstairs the lock went to
downstairs not to this room that had the
money in it I'm telling you there's
bodies in that downstairs room that
there was no money in there cuz we know
the money's right but maybe he was
trying to protect the world from
something as opposed to keeping
something in there I don't know may we
should call the cops before he do this
come I'm actually in agreement with him
I'd rather go to jail me
too how are you going to make it out
want more than 300 Grand in that there
got to be about a million dollars okay
let's get out of here how he boarded up
everything he locked the
doors the storm doors both from the
inside that can be way
on no no o o o o o no
no this actress is awesome she is but I
also think he's awesome too Steph I know
he's awesome too I just KN I knew him
and
her remember when the guy money said
move this way or whatever I feel like
Steven Lang knows there more than one
person in the house yeah he's very
intuitive
also who know who knows how visually
impaired he is no no no
jeez oh my
God is that the mirror
[Music]
Jesus I didn't know a vibrating phone
could get on me like that is that mone's
phone or is that one of their phones I
don't know whose phone that
was I know they both should have a
phone yeah this movie is like the longer
extended scarier version of in Matilda
when they went into Miss trunchbull's
house and they were trying to escape
Miss honey and Matilda I don't know if
you remember that I do I think
downstairs is the chokey well the chokey
was at school Roxy just saying was in
Miss trench's office right this that was
my joke no something's up down here no
no no no no remember this was locked
y'all whatever's down here is worse
they're like I just want to get away
from this guy I don't care where we have
to
go [__]
night I wonder how much of a challenge
this was for the actors too cuz the how
this is
lit it had to be brighter and they did
oh and they just imp yeah cuz otherwise
you're so dangerous right it's like guys
we keep hitting things can't see oh
no problem is when you lose one sense
you gain a lot in the others what do you
think he's smelling
perfume that could POS be a POS he might
walk them
downstairs oh the shoes ooh he's going
to find two pairs
uh-oh oh
no
damn uhoh okay so I got two more people
here no not two more I think that one of
these remember CU didn't Dylan grab his
own shoes oh that's right that's right
think one at least one that's a good
point cuz one of those is Money
shoes I was to check there's no money in
there oh [__] oh
no oh
no oh now I'm on the hunt they took my
money
am I well now he should call the cops
but he just killed somebody but it was
in his own house I just say I never want
harm T anyone but I'm not I'm not even
rooting for these guys like they went
into this guy's house and stole from him
yeah completely the the thing that's
going to change our minds as an audience
is if what's down here then we stop
rooting for him depending on what is
what does he what atrocities has he
committed even though again we saw a
little glimpse of it at the
beginning
Bell just wrong oh no oh
Andrew what the hell was
that what here right now come on he
can't help her
out oh I want to see what's on that note
is that his
daughter we can leave right
now innocent of oh that's the one who
was accused of his daughter oh she's the
one who killed his daughter oh we have
to get her out of here oh my God you can
get her out once you
leave it's
safe oh my God move move are you guys
nuts Stop
Standing the movie's called Don't
breathe not don't
move but I'm telling you I think that
she might not be she might be a menace
to Society it might not be
him oh the backup remember the backups
that he wouldn't leave with the security
yep no she's
evil I don't know something's wrong you
don't trust her you don't trust no I
don't I
don't oh no he's going to meet them out
on the other
end oh no oh no oh no they are making so
much noise he's going to be right there
Purge Purge
no no what's wrong it's locked don't you
have the
keys Dy show me come on oh I like
actually have to close my eyes I feel
sick I'll just I'll I'll commentary
what's
happening no no he's right there he's
right there ah he's going to be on the
other
side
oh
jeez oh she was help what oh she got
shot oh no
oh
[Music]
Jesus this dude has said like like three
lines all moving and I'm beyond
terrified of him what were the three
lines or whatever he said like how many
of you are there or something whatever
it
was it must have just been an accident
that that was it oh my God he's about to
realize that he killed the
girl this is the time to run out right
now or like bum rush him or something I
don't know if you're going to bum rush
him he's built like a tank I know but if
I'm them you like you got to try to run
out and if not you got to try to get the
gun something can't just sit there no no
for sure for sure
no
no also I don't know about the term I
just used now that I'm thinking about it
is that a PC term which term P Rush it's
fine it's turning getting rid of the
electricity whose hands have the
keys oh he's locking it
oh oh he's breaking these keys they nice
locked on the front
door oh broke it he shoved that thing in
there so they couldn't use it
yeah
oh and he shot the phone so they don't
have a flashlight
yeah the sound design is wickedly insane
they've got to take him
[Music]
out do you think there's anybody else
down here I I don't think
so do you think that was the body he was
dragging though at the beginning was
that girl or was that someone else
that's what I'm curious about I'm not
sure cuz it would looked like blood that
was being right she seemed
unharmed all we know is this newspaper
article they assumed that this was the
woman that killed his daughter his
daughter but I don't know maybe this was
his other daughter and he was trying to
keep her safe and the body was the
person who shot the like I'm letting my
mind wander right right maybe he's
actually actually going to speak some
lines and let us S no no no this is shot
so scary oh my God no no she's going to
walk right into him I would not be
moving right now stop moving I know I
told you to move before but stop
moving no no
oh do
not she almost literally go deaf from
that too in real
life that got me that got me
good
oh oh my God that is so
scary did she just help him with that I
don't think think so cuz it looks like
she hasn't moved
rocky rocky rocky Roy let's go let's go
way way but what but why are we now just
talking free willly come on come on no
no no what's up there oh did he lock it
no I don't I don't know is he did he get
up
there I feel like he would know every I
mean if there's what's up there
something something else got out run oh
it's a dog cuz remember that it was only
supposed to keep him sleep like Y what
they assumed was a 10 15 minute job go
to the
door what do you do with the dog I don't
know I just don't like animals getting
harmed on film and TV I feel like he
went outside oh no he's going to hit it
with the Crowbar oh
no oh I hate animals getting harmed in
movies and TV there's a website that
tells you that oh when it happens in
what movies yeah
no oh they lost the keys oh they're
going to go in the gas
room maybe that's the Dodger's bedroom
okay everything's boarded or B yeah and
it's like
why what are you doing I'm pressing the
panic button if I manage to get in range
the system will call 911 and the police
will wait we can't go to jail yes go to
jail okay this is robbery versus
kidnapping and murder the police won't
care about us but then we wouldn't keep
the money are you an idiot Rocky you
you'll keep your lives you don't get to
keep the money if you're dead honey
she's like I'll take the
risk
go hit the button don't listen to her
seriously he's listened to her too many
times she's going to find something
something crazy up
here oh oh ah ah he's dead how would you
survive that oh no oh no well even if
you survived that I don't know about
this part cuz now he's outside the house
but he's about to be back inside the
house yet again that would really
hurt oh no this is not
good oh no oh no no oh and that's making
the cracking noise he's going to hear
that maybe he falls right on him though
he's got to be alive because otherwise
the movie is not as entertaining I get
it Jail's no fun but like better than
the alternative oh wow is the dog going
in there oh my God smart dog
Jesus oh my God damn that is a very
intuitive I do not want to see what
happens right
now
go oh
boo you up hey boo you up nope don't do
that it's going to get shot up right
now oh my
God
no
jeez dude these bullet sound designs are
so jump
scary did he hit it hit the button hit
the button no
no where's the dog I wonder if he
disabled the
alarm did he get him I don't know no I
think he got him I don't think so I
think he's holding himself from
the oh wait that's her oh no different
person I think it's where she fell out
of if they hold their breath we have to
that's I I've been doing it the whole
movie no no he breathes oh yeah he heard
that this dude is
Relentless oh
no
oh
ah oh my
God wo
wo the noise
yeah
y he almost had the
[Music]
gun
reach oh
oh oh he disabled
that oh
no I actually like his character oh
God I think that answered your question
[__] where did he just hit him I
couldn't tell but I think he's in the
same place as money okay but at this
point does Steven Lang think he's gotten
everybody he did hear him say he did
hear him say say her name out right so I
don't know he's intutive I think he
knows yeah I think so
too
again because of the lighting was hard
did she fall hard on yeah I think she
went down a shoot okay just again it
just broke her
legs there's no way he locked that off
did he oh my God I hit oh it's just
naturally locked oh cuz it's it's screw
bolted the fingers through the
whatever
damn
oh God how is she going to survive this
remember when we saw Dy manetti next to
a body it seemed like was there another
body there that could have been
money but I don't know I think it was
her oh crap Jesus does nobody survive in
this movie I don't know but he felt to
see that she was a woman just now did he
put her to sleep or did he permanently
put her to sleep oh maybe he ties her up
downstairs you're
thinking okay yeah okay but the thing
about Dylan manetti's character is that
he has the keys so his dad if he ever
looks he'll see those keys for this
place are gone right well I thought he
said that the back didn't he say the
backup keys that he kept them that
Stephen Lang kept them yeah but he still
had one key and they said why would he
only give one key not the other backup
keys
right oh oh poor
thing damn he bruised her up I
understand you she killed her daughter I
wanted her to pay I'm not sure that's
what happened you understand nothing
only a parent can know the oh bond
between a father and his child uhoh I
hate torture she should have gone to
prison but rich girls don't go to
jail okay none of this is going to bring
your daughter back that's not really
true
Cindy took my child away from me so he's
trying to make a new daughter it's only
fair that she give me a new one oh he
impregnated her uhoh that's why he was
so sad when she died pregnant with my
baby
oh you killed them both well they would
be alive if you hadn't broken into my
home uh is this going to be the new yeah
of course
oh I guess that's why you didn't kill
her you have to be held
accountable yeah that is such an crazy
thing like to do that to the person oh
my God is he
alive I think now I know what uh wait
wait wait who is this oh my
god oh cuz there was another body oh he
put it in a different body yeah but what
is that
body I can't believe he's still alive
cuz he didn't get no no no I know but
just from yeah that was really cool shot
he's seriously so freaking strong it's
like those are little oh the dog no
don't hurt the dog no he's got it I know
I
know okay okay thank you I'm good with
that that works for
[Music]
me tar
cement oh puts it in the floor
oh so he has to know that he needs to
get out of the house in order to help
her right like he's not going to go
downstairs and try to help her he
wouldn't be a movie character if he
didn't go downstairs right yeah but I'm
a little worried cuz the alarm's going
to go off right and then he's going to
hear the alarm go
off what are you doing oh
Lordy I never forced myself on her oh I
promised I would set her free just as
soon as she gave me a child
now she's
gone but I'm done
waiting no no no what are you going to
do
wait so he's going to inseminate
her you can't do this to me oh okay I
understand well okay so he's going to
inseminate her right
yeah this is such an insane 9
months and I will give you your life
back oh my
[Music]
god oh oh Dylan's man's character went
downstairs what who H
ho but he hasn't killed him yet I'm
super nervous right now you got to kill
the guy also dude this guy is so tough
like he smashed him in the hand earlier
and that didn't phase him at
all
oh guys get out of the
house oh he's going to do it anyway oh
oh o that was is Rocky Rocky it's over
come on it's not over o o or he can get
out of this or
something oh no oh oh he hits the alarm
going to rot in prison for what you've
done we can't involve the cops now if we
steal a million in cash and then leave
the cops here he'll tell them about us
you got what you came for I'll take it
get out of my
house he needs us to take the money it's
one or the other but if you choose with
you there's a little urgency here that I
feel like you guys aren't keeping up
with I think he's coming for them I
don't know oh no what's out there what's
out there I know but he got out for sure
he
did oh no oh no they're about to die
three two one dead dead dead yeah he
went out the other way
oh I don't think he survived this one
no oh did she leave the bag or did she
take it no she left it you think it's on
her back yeah it's on her back maybe it
saves her life no he's coming for her oh
no no no no no don't turn back oh my God
you're worthless out
here ah the
dog why did she say he's worthless out
here I mean he knows that house inside
and out even without his being able to
see going to be able to
jump this interesting I thought once we
got out of the house the movie was going
to be over oh my
god oh she doesn't have the
money back to where we started the dog
at the at the car
door oh oh my
goodness oh no no no no you're screwed
but the backpack's outside came out no
she's dead I feel it oh good call what
do you feel what do
you what do you do drive
or
what she has no keys does money have the
keys cuz money was the drive
right what do you do call the cops now I
don't know I don't know I wonder if
Steven Lang's character just like walks
up and grabs the bag I mean
can what's she going to
do what does she have back
there oh she's going to trap the dog in
there
she going to close the trunk on it or
go cuz remember she used to get stuck in
the trunk or locked in the trunk yeah oh
no oh
no oh my
God that one tough
dog
I know he's going to be there somehow I
mean the dog has made a lot of noise oh
no hate it no no no
no oh wow did he bring her back inside
this a Non-Stop roller coaster ride this
film oh this is the body we saw him
dragging oh from the beginning yes it is
wow she's actually dragging her back
towards the
house
wow interesting that they chose to show
that nonlinear storytelling I like that
what's your prediction I I mean he said
he would let her live or have her life
after 9 months oh
ladybug make a wish but is your
prediction that she gets out right now
or
no no what's your prediction
oh I maybe she's going to hit the alarm
there there's the prediction I guess
yeah she chooses she doesn't choose the
money yeah finally see she sees the
light
oh
ooh ooh those are not replaceable what
is she going to tell the
cops
oh how is this dude still
alive that's a metal crowbar I'm scared
right now
though I think in her mind at that point
prison was better than nine months
trapped in their uh right but now he's
dead is he I don't know
maybe the cops shoot her right
now oh the cops are there what is she
going to
do they see
her do you think they saw her or no I
don't think
[Music]
so and
credits so she did get it both ways oh
now she's taking her sister to
California you and me at the beach I can
imagine that's a lot of ptst for the
rest of her life last night two burglars
broke into his home and attempted to Rob
and brutally attack him doctors say he
is in stable condition what no goods
were reported stolen by the victim what
is she going to do uh just travel to
California and never look back I mean
he's not going to find her I don't think
she's capable no cuz she's upset that
he's the hero now and doesn't go to
prison I don't think she's
capable cuz he Resto reported no good
stolen
boy that was
tery Purge Purge
Purge wow Sam
Ry I should have known fedy alare is I
feel like his name is familiar too did
he do an evil dead thing or
something I also don't know that
franchise I feel like his name came up
recently
though wow did you breathe the whole
time holy crap that was still not
breathing what a wild wild wild watch oh
my go first of all before we get into
the review if you are watching this on
Apple or Spotify if you would not mind
rating this Roxy myself and all of us
here five stars baby yeah if you don't
mind rating us please we'd really
appreciate it uh that was such an
intense right I mean the film just
really just it it hit the Go Button like
a like a roller coaster ride and just
did not it's like did not let up from
start to finish well at least one once
we got into the house at least it just
does not let up it's like the main like
Steven Lang this film is Relentless it's
so crazy is that it does it asks of its
audience members to continue guessing
right like you don't know when we get
upstairs and we see stepen Lang for the
first time kind of sleeping and it's
like wait is this like a little old
man's house that they've broken into uh
what exactly is going on here to the
point where I really like you I'm like
our protagonists are definitely our
antagonists like the people that we're
following I can't stand them they're
they're doing this to him they're in the
wrong right and then when we when we
find out what's actually in the basement
it was so smart of them to have us see
that lock so that the whole time in my
mind I don't believe he's the good guy
but but even then I thought maybe he was
trying to protect them from whatever
like there was a monster in the basement
and he was trying to keep it from
getting out I just didn't ever this
movie was always ahead of me no for sure
I mean I thought there was multiple or a
lot of bodies that he had done because I
figured too after his daughter like I
mean you can understand in a s after
something like that you you just might
lose it and I thought like too when when
we saw the first body which again a cool
reveal that no that was one of the main
characters that was just nonlinear
storytelling I love that reveal too I
believe it was cuz we saw like the smear
on the street too from when he was
dragging the body so um so that's why I
just again like you said the film was
just ahead of us I just figured there
was multiple bodies and I just had no
idea what was going on but the reveal
again then what was going on I know we
got to be careful how we we say what was
really happening with the girl in there
uh you know we had we saw the newspaper
headline that uh she was innocent of all
charges with manslaughter and then we
find out what he was truly
doing I I I'm trying to word out I want
to say this I don't agree with how he
was doing it but I can understand his
motivation for a child after what had
happened it was interesting that it like
I love characters that play by their own
rules and have their own set of morals
right and so while he doesn't mind uh
you know putting somebody tied up while
he clearly when what he did to money
immediately for thinking that he was
being a burglar yet he says I'm I'm down
here and he goes to inseminate her
because what he's not going to do is
force himself on somebody and it was
like everybody has their own moral code
what a freaking bizarre one that that is
your line but it made for what you were
talking about which is like you got your
daughter taken and so you you his logic
is obviously unbelievably flawed and
Disturbed but you see what happened
there you see him be like my daughter
was taken I'm owed a daughter therefore
this is how the universe will pay me
back and the fact that he continues to
say I was gonna let her go after nine
months I don't know if you had the same
thought I did but I'm thinking this poor
girl would have been better off if they
had left her to she would have lived
yeah not better off right and obviously
they didn't know that but yes obviously
and I don't know that he really would
have who's to say that that's what he
would have done he might have he might
have uh killed her because you know
obviously she would have known what had
happened she and she could have outed
him and he clearly didn't want to get
caught otherwise he would have said that
they took the money from him you know so
that's a good point I mean yeah because
if he would have the the girl that was
Aid the one who was uh guilt or not
guilty of manslaughter like yeah so she
has the kid he lets her go and then like
she could have like you said she could
have outed him and then like cuz I mean
that's your kidnapping you held a woman
against her will uh for nine months so I
mean she could get amongst other things
yeah yeah for sure so um his plan like
you said was flawed and um just
misguided so I'm very curious like cuz I
was thinking that in the back of my head
I'm like if you do let her go you're
going to go to prison like even if you
have a kid yeah so uh but yeah no um
very unless he was planning on moving or
something you know yeah what was the my
my main the only point of confusion that
I really did have with this movie is
that body that ends up with the the big
sword the the trimmers I think that was
money I don't because it didn't like I
said but he would have known that
because he put M's body somewhere no he
he was taking he was dragging mone's
body and then he started hearing noise
and then I I but I just would think cuz
he had he had such awareness of where
everything was the whole time if that's
where he left money's body you're right
he did have awareness of everything
especially in that house but I mean he
was in an ensuing battle with Alex is
that his name Dylan Dylan character he
was in an ensuing battle when you're in
a battle like that especially too with
with his uh situation where he was uh
you know uh imp impaired uh with his
eyes I mean visually impaired thank you
he was impaired with his eyes visually
impaired thank you uh where he was
visually impaired I mean it's
understandable in a situation like that
and the body was like within a foot or
so of Alex so it's understandably so
that he might think that that was who he
hit the whole thing is understandably so
except for the fact that they do paint
him as Daredevil so if he's Daredevil
you know where you put the body but I
get but I get where you're I of course I
would have not known but they made him
into this like like all knowing even
when downstairs he turns off the lights
you saw the way he was tapping the top
top part he knows every inch of his home
he knows where everything is it's not
pulling me out as and I'm like that's so
unrealistic it it just made me question
is this another body that I'm unaware of
and maybe I'm harping on semantics
because it's probably just money and I'm
probably overthinking it but it did make
me think like wait what is happening
here cuz then there was that other
moment too where he ends up next to a
body um and I was like is that her body
that fell or what because of how dark it
was I I think that that on purpose well
they had blurry things bodies going
around I did I think they wanted us to
be in the dark a little bit figuratively
right I'm going to assume it was money
because again we didn't see many other
bodies in that downstairs where that
that woman was being uh held captive so
and again aside from you know having
self-defense and his home and I mean
money really did deserve what happened
to him he was holding the gun right at
the guy's head after he they had uh you
know tried robbing him so you know aside
from that like he didn't seem like and
and again aside from also his flawed and
misguided thing of what he was doing to
that poor woman uh as well but we didn't
know that at this time right right right
I'm just I'm just just generally
speaking after the fact I I I I don't
think he was an evil human being besides
that in general like I'm going to go out
and start just murdering people so I I I
think that was I'm pretty sure whoa whoa
you didn't think he was evil no no no I
said aside from he was doing to that to
that poor girl like that was I I just
mean in generality like I don't think I
he was targeted I I think he was e as
evil comes but he was targeted in being
evil in terms of he doesn't seem like a
mass murderer yeah that's what I mean
he's not going out like hey Just for
kicks I'm just going to start like
killing people you know what I mean
liketh felt like he had a bad hand dealt
to him in terms of his daughter he's uh
Hey the world owes me so I'm ow a kid
now I'm going to take it out now on this
woman who took my child going to get a
child of her I guess I'm I'm going to
let her go now and now these people are
coming into my home they're stealing
from me uh self-defense trespassing in
my territory like I I just mean like
he's not like when we're asking is that
money is that someone else I just don't
think he's going out getting other
bodies and that's someone else I think
that was money but again it's so tly
it's the with how the lighting was it
was hard to tell but I'm pretty sure I
agree with you that it was money but I
do think also flawed logic doesn't just
happen after you deal with grief right
like when you're dealing with grief you
become one of two things better or
bitter he clearly became bitter and
that's what caused all of this to happen
but that was a seed that was obviously
already inside him I don't think he
lived this like beautiful perfect life
and he was an amazing father and never
did he harm anybody and then the day his
daughter died he was like actually I'm
going to kidnap this girl that got off
and I'm going to put her in my basement
and then I'm going to inseminate her and
then make her have my kid and let her go
like I think he probably already was
super duper flawed and which makes me
think he already might have been um
doing some form of kidnapping tortur
something I don't who's to say that's
not the point of this movie but I I
don't think you know what do they say
trauma explains Behavior it doesn't
excuse it so I do think this they did
explain it here but I don't think that
this is like a brand knew before this he
was standup Citizen and to your point
too he was an Army veteran he had you
know probably who knows the PTSD was
going through and he was visually
impaired from being a veteran too so I
mean he could have just been like you
know just gone off the deep end even
before his daughter just from that alone
I mean or not I guess it's yeah one one
way or the other but I do I think that
he was such perfect casting for this the
acting from Steven Lang and also too uh
not sure what that actress's name uh was
it was it Rocky or Roxy it was Rocky
Rocky okay but they they at the end I
saw and I recognized her name she is is
so she was fantastic she is so good uh
oh my gosh I think everything your eyes
are so essential especially in a movie
where there's not as much dialogue
because it's called Don't breathe which
implies not speaking it everything was
in her eyes but also she's maybe my
least favorite character in the whole
movie because like you did this to us
babes you were like I need this money
and then you had every opportunity to
get saved but you just still wanted the
money you killed your boyfriend you
killed your best friend cuz you wanted
the money to get out of a situation that
sucked but like oh my God you crazy it's
like kind of not nice that she gets to
live her life now I agree with you and I
disagreed with what she was doing but it
was a good thing they did show us the
situation she was dealing with and also
we got a little into her backstory
through the dialogue and Exposition so
we could sympathize with her even though
it was very illogical what she was doing
and not smart uh and obviously it cost
money and Alex their lives due to her
poor decision making so that was her
little sister not her daughter right I
believe that was her little sister yeah
yeah I mean I sister stuff pulls on my
heartstrings as a big sis I would do
anything for my little sister to get her
out but this doesn't this goes past the
point of anything like you can't just
there's other ways there are better ways
to make money like you just can't and
and from the start and I love that this
movie did this when we're stuck in the
closet and they could leave but in
instead she memorizes the code and she
does the code then like four more times
when uh she goes through the vent and
and she's like no no we got to get out
of here with the money then when she
finally is when they're finally almost
at the door and he's like you have to
choose is it the money or him getting
arrested and she chooses the money again
just I think this this movie had a lot
of strong messages and it's like what
matters to you the most because
sometimes you get to prioritized things
and sometimes you only get one thing and
what is is it wow yeah that was they
killed this yeah no like I said very
suspenseful terrifying uh film and again
Stephen Lang I mean you already said
that there wasn't a lot of exposition
but he literally had two scenes of
dialogue in this entire film he had the
one where he says to uh money how many
other people are there with you and then
he had that other scene uh with Rocky
where he was just explaining like uh you
know what had happened with him uh and I
believe that was it I mean but masterful
performances from all uh really scene at
the the one scene where he has her uh
that's what you're talking about when he
explains yeah yeah that that whole scene
yeah um but also need a name for the
scene yeah right I lik what you were was
saying earlier but uh I will say this
for a film that's an hour and 25 27
minutes whatever it was like it felt
longer than that just because of the
ride we were on like you know I
completely agree with you so funny but I
I remember one time looking down to see
how long it been because I was thinking
to myself it feel like I've been here
for 2 hours I don't mean that as a knock
on the movie agreed I just honestly felt
like I don't know how much longer I can
take this yes that's that's how I meant
it too when it's not a knock on pacing
or anything I actually thought it was
past well and it ended up like at the
appropriate time as well but I'm like it
feels so much longer than it is not in a
bad way so totally agree with you there
this movie kind of drove me
insane like genuinely while we are
watching it all the predicting and all
of the wondering and all of the like
squeaks in the floor and button pushes
and the dog being there I felt trapped I
felt like I could not breathe it's
obviously the title for a reason in the
movie but I feel like it was a message
to us like I I should have paid more
attention going in that this was going
to be so effing scary yeah no for sure I
hope this film makes people think again
if they want to steal from a blind
person if you want to steal from anybody
yeah well especially a blind person
who's an army vet and has lost a child
yeah cuz they thought this was going to
be easy what was it you said when they
were going in you were like they're
going to think this is going to be 5 10
minutes and it is not yeah that's why
they they put that thing in the for the
dog to eat and they're like this is
going to be a 10-minute job and that's
it simple easy what did you feel about
the very small amount of
characters I actually liked that I mean
we didn't need because we're it's
literally 95% of the film is set in one
location which I thought was good that
that added to the claustrophobia feel to
the film yeah so I mean we didn't really
need more characters than we had we had
the three uh character the
thieves and then you have Steven Lang's
character and then you have the little
sister I mean I I mean I felt that was
actually appropriate to have especially
if you're going to be at one location
like that throughout the whole film I
was completely fine how' you feel about
it I really liked it too I did keep
wondering if Alex's dad was going to
play a part because they had taken the
keys and kind of dropped that seed and I
was wondering you know is he going to
notice is he going to save the day but
other than that I really felt like there
was a it was a perfect amount and
usually a movie like this it feels
really small budget if there's so few
characters but in this it was just it
was kind of like a bottle movie I mean
we're in the house almost the entire
time I love movies like this I watched
on this channel I watched hush before
did you see that I have not seen hush oh
it was so good also um home invasion
movies really freak me the F out but
typically we start in the home in those
movies right and we're trying to fend
off but in this one we were they were
asking us to root for people breaking
into a house uh at least for them in
some sense and so that's why I feel like
this was a really fresh take on a
category that's already been so so
overdone in the horror space yeah well I
mean I was rooing for Rocky to get out
of that lifestyle especially from that
one guy who's got that disgusting tattoo
and just that broken down home style
that she was in but if you put as much
effort into your thievery into another
job you probably just make a lot of
money anyways just say you were rooting
for her I was rooting for was no no I
was rooting well yeah I actually liked
Alex like he was like let's get out of
here let's not do this like I mean he
actually had a very uh you know sense of
uh like logicality so uh him I actually
like he could have hit the button at any
time I know but he he was he was just
really drawn to Rocky and he just that
just wavered over uh you know any smart
decision making he wanted to do not to
everyone out there it's beautiful to be
in love but when it's unrequited love
and she's with somebody else you just
can't put both your lives on the line
stay in the friend zone just uh make the
smart decision yeah uh what did you
think about the lighting stuff I know
that you a couple times are like it's
really dark it it actually play yeah
because he's visually impaired it almost
gives us a view into what he can and
can't see literally so I like it too
because like when they can't see they're
in his world literally like it's his
house but it's also his world because
only he even though he can't see like he
know he can hear everything but they
can't see as well so it's like even the
playing field it really was I loved it
actually um but I I was fine with it I
mean there's a lot there's films that
have been criticized uh for bad lighting
like alien verse Predator requium I
don't know if you've ever seen that but
it's I haven't seen it but I know it's
got like one of the worst uh lighting of
any films like in movie history worst
isn't poorly done or super dark both
both okay yeah I didn't think this was
poorly done no no no it was again I just
for the style they were going for and
then with Steven character I actually
appreciated it personally yeah there
were a few times like what's happening
what and then like as we got the reveal
that his character couldn't really see
it was like okay now I understand what
they're going for and then like the
silhouette shots it just added to the
terror and the suspense too and there
was something you said a couple of times
that I was already thinking like when
characters were not this isn't even a
lit thing but where characters were
reaching fingers through them like
what's going on on the other side my
mind's playing tricks now and what's
about to happen but we did actually get
revealed shots because like when they
were when they finally got out from the
under the uh the cellar like he was
always waiting on the other side because
again it's his world it's his domain he
knows every place to go in that in that
in that home of his so what do you think
about the fact that there's a don't
breathe
too oh there is a don't breathe too
there's a I'm only asking you that
because this feels so Standalone but we
here at the end of this movie that he
made it and he's in the hospital I was
going to say that too I know he's an
army fan how did he all that I know he's
built like a truck um I mean I really
enjoyed this one so I'm curious what the
storyline would be for that I mean
because he I mean everything was built
upon like in his home and domain so I
don't know if I see him going after that
uh Rocky and all that I feel like her
story is done I don't know like what you
would do for the second one but I mean
if you guys are interested in seeing
Roxy and myself react to that one i' I'd
be I'd be down for some me being being a
[__] jump scares again I'm sorry I'm
Pur you're so rude of me no no no you're
good um but I'm a [__] all the time no
it's it's all but in regards to
storyline I I mean I my only assumption
is he wants to have a kid again a child
I other than that I don't know where
what else he would do storyline wise
what would you think of I'm curious
about it yeah the only the way they
leave it I don't know I think that it
could start with Rocky being like I took
this money hand giving herself in or
whatever but I'm not sure she's in it I
don't know I really don't know but you
took the words out of my mouth before
with if you guys want us to watch it
then like this video comment let us know
if you want us to do don't breathe too
what did you think about this movie were
you watching it for the first time along
with us and were you holding your breath
the whole time like us did I steal your
to ask nope it was I feel like I uh it
was an assist okay and a layup it was a
dunk Laker fan to Celtic FL fan it was
one two punch it was a uh who are CU I
don't know I was going to say thelman
Louise but we're not thma and Louise it
was a a one and two who are two people
that what's a buddy cop girl guy thing
buddy cop uh Rigs and mertop but that's
not a guy girl uh I don't know Scully
and Moulder there you oh that's a good
one I like that let go let us know
thanks so much reject you guys rock and
we will see you maybe for don't bre
two m